time dilation the fifth dimension
gravity's ability to transcend time and
space yep if you watched christopher
nolan's sci-fi epic interstellar and
ended up with more questions than
answers you are not alone here are the
most confusing moments of interstellar
explained
professor brand is the father of
astronaut dr emilia brand and has
dedicated his entire life and career to
solving the gravity equation once he
passes away murph takes on the
responsibility of searching for the
answer but throughout the movie it is
never made clear what exactly they have
been after what is apparent is the
purpose once this mysterious equation is
solved humans will be able to use
gravitational anomalies to manipulate
gravity and to safely get everyone off
the planet the snag in the plan is that
the data from inside a black hole is
needed to complete it no one has ever
seen inside a black hole so there was no
way to get the data until cooper for
obvious reasons the movie couldn't get
into the gritty scientific details of
the fake equation but what is important
to know is that anomalies are crucial to
the solution and a black hole is the
biggest anomaly of all when coop goes
inside the black hole gargantua at the
end of interstellar and transmits that
data to murf she is finally able to
solve the equation and save humanity
the opening 30 minutes of interstellar
are confusing on the first watch through
and perhaps even after a repeat viewing
during that first act you might be left
wondering what this whole ghost story
has to do with space travel and saving
the human race well as it turns out
everything by the end of the movie you
will learn that cooper is the ghost or
gravitational anomaly trying to
communicate with mirth through time
while he is in the tesseract when coop
is inside the tesseract he realizes he
can communicate with young murph via the
bookshelf we see the mirror image of an
earlier scene where the ghost spells out
the word stay through morse code here we
learned that it is actually cooper
trying to convince himself not to leave
murf behind
at this point in the story cooper
regrets ever leaving and tries to change
the past although it cannot be done coop
can travel through the dimension of time
though and he uses the bookshelf to
communicate the solution to professor
brand's formula when she visits the
house in the present timeline
perhaps the single most confusing moment
of interstellar is the significance of
the watch that cooper gives to murph
when she is a child in a moment of anger
she breaks it but it stays in the house
for years when cooper goes into
gargantua and winds up in the tesseract
he sends murph a coded message that
solves the gravity equation he does this
by using gravity which is a force that
transcends time according to the film to
move the hands of the watch and
communicate with murph in morse code
by manipulating gravity he can cause the
broken watch to tick encode and transmit
the information to save humanity there
are many theories as to how exactly this
works because the film never explains it
cleanly since time isn't passing for
coop he can potentially spend as much
time as he wants perhaps even years
transmitting what he needs murph to know
considering all the time she loses while
he's away though perhaps the watch as a
medium is really just a symbol of his
urgency to finish the mission and
reunite with his daughter
back in 2014 it wasn't advertised that
matt damon would make an appearance in
interstellar so when he showed up on an
icy planet as the stranded scientist dr
mann nolan fans were shocked by the
surprise but as cooper and man spend
more time together cooper starts to
realize that man is more than a little
shady as it turns out man has faked the
data that indicates life on the planet
is possible if he'd told the truth he
would have been left to die instead he
lies and waits in cryosleep until
another nasa team inevitably shows up to
respond to his signal man's plan is then
to hijack the ship of whoever comes for
him and leave them stranded this selfish
act of self-preservation very likely
could have ended in man in eternal
cryosleep so why was that the plan in
interstellar man represents the human
drive to stay alive
don't judge me cooper
he was never tested like i was
human habit
he goes to extremes and would rather
potentially wait in cryosleep for
thousands of years instead of dying his
plan has a major flaw but it is a risk
he's willing to take since the
alternative is freezing to death
one of the most confusing moments of
interstellar has nothing to do with
interdimensional travel or quantum
physics it is instead a choice made by
murph as the film reaches its climax
while riding in the car away from the
childhood home murph jumps out of the
truck and then proceeds to light her
brother tom's cornfield on fire
at this point in the timeline those
crops are vital to the survival of not
just her family but the entire remainder
of the human race so why such an extreme
action from a character who genuinely
loves her brother this weird out of
character moment makes more sense when
you realize murph is merely buying time
and using this sports-to-earth measure
as a desperate distraction she needs to
go back inside the house to finish what
she started as a child from an earlier
scene we already know that tom will no
longer listen to murph so she needs to
do something extreme to distract him
while she tries to find the solution to
her equation luckily she does manage to
figure out how to save the planet in
that 15 minute window she's created for
herself otherwise tom would be mighty
upset upon returning to the farm and the
whole family would be much worse off a
major twist in the second half of
interstellar is that the elder dr brand
who sends his own granddaughter and
cooper on the mission knows everyone
still on earth is doomed to die nasa
first sends the explorers into space
with a plan a and a plan b devised by dr
brand plan a is to find a habitable
planet and then once bran solves his
gravity equation back on earth send the
planet's remaining population to that
new home however brand actually doesn't
plan on solving the equation and knows
it is going to be plan b all along each
iteration is an attempt to prove its own
proof it's
recursive it's nonsensical in the case
of plan b cooper and the others will
find a suitable habitat to rebuild
humanity with thousands of frozen
embryos thus keeping the human race
alive but dooming earth bran knows coop
will not go through with the mission if
he tells him the truth he can't tell his
daughter for the same reason but on an
even deeper level he can't face telling
her what he's done so he keeps that a
secret until his dying breath when he
finally reveals the dark truth to murph
even fans of nolan's film catalog have
called out interstellar for being
ridiculous to a fault with certain
conceits one of these moments is the
movie's final twist where cooper doesn't
just survive a black hole encounter but
finds himself transcending linear time
the scene inside the tesseract requires
serious suspension of disbelief to make
sense throughout the film coop and murph
repeatedly refer to a mysterious day
that they believe to be communicating
with them prompted mostly by the ghost
and its messages this is the central
mystery that wraps up in the tesseract
scene where it is revealed that cooper
is the one communicating with murph
through the bookshelf this scene also
explains what the tesseract is and who
built it as it turns out they did and
they are humans from an unspecified
number of generations in the future at
that untold point in time they have
evolved to be able to exist in the fifth
dimension in the paradox inducing
explanation this future generation
creates the tesseract that allows cooper
to navigate five dimensions thus saving
themselves from the past and ensuring
their own existence
the monologue brand gives near the end
of the movie is a controversial subject
to say the least it gets a lot of hate
but defenders will rally in droves to
tell you it's one of the most important
parts of the movie and they are right
you need to take it seriously in the
infamous speech brand explains that love
is the only thing that transcends all
five dimensions she argues that love is
something that exists and is
quantifiable which ultimately ends up
being what cooper needs to save earth
the only way he is able to contact murph
through the bookshelf in gargantua is
through their familial love connection
coop even exclaims it's just like grand
said my connection with murph it is
quantifiable it's the key
in an added layer of meaning it is also
humanity's love for each other that
inspires them to build the tesseract and
save the past generation
interstellar has what many would
consider a happy ending coop makes it
back to earth in time to see his
daughter one last time she can die
having gotten the final bit of closure
she needs and he can be free to live his
life unburdened the secret tragedy is
that coop makes it home too late to
spend any significant amount of time
with his daughter or perhaps we have
just stumbled upon a plot contrivance by
the end murph is an elderly woman who
has stayed alive long enough to finally
see her father again who looks the same
as when he left decades ago the whole
movie is built on this relationship so
people are rightfully confused as to why
they only spend a few minutes together
murph now realizes this reunion is the
last thing that is driving her to live
and she can finally let go she even says
to coop that she doesn't have much time
left and that a father shouldn't watch
their child die even given this you
would think coop and murph would each
want some more than just five minutes it
is a stunningly brief final encounter
considering how much energy he spends
trying to return to her in the first
place
understanding the emotional core at the
center of interstellar requires
understanding how time dilation works
once the crew of the endurance reaches
miller's planet full of treacherous
waves it is assumed the audience
understands this concept but how exactly
does the time dilation make sense in
interstellar the explanation the movie
gives is that a difference in
gravitational force causes time to move
at different speeds on different planets
this dilation effect is accelerated when
in the case of millers the planet is
orbiting a black hole as the force of
gravity increases time moves at an
accelerated pace while coop and his crew
only spent a few hours crash-landed on
miller's planet 23 years have passed on
earth according to scientist neil
degrasse tyson this detail of
interstellar is a scientific phenomenon
that exists for real this can be proven
by einstein's equation of general
relativity that's relativity folks one
of the first unanswered questions you
might have when you watch interstellar
is when exactly does the movie take
place it's a good question that isn't
ever explicitly stated in christopher
nolan's movie however you can piece a
relatively precise estimate together
based on a conversation from early on in
the film in one of the first scenes we
see coop attending a baseball game with
his family in an offhanded comment to
his family coop's father-in-law says my
day we had real ball players who are
these bumps and in the scene where
donald and cooper talk on the porch the
elder says when i was a kid it felt like
they made something new every day
some
gadget or idea this sounds a lot like
what growing up in the past 10 to 15
years has been like we can safely assume
that between growing up with
professional baseball and technology
donald is a millennial using this
knowledge we can place the events of
interstellar about 50 to 60 years after
present day 2014 when the movie came out
this means the film probably takes place
in the late 21st century
while even donald's demise gets a
passing reference dad didn't raise me
grandpa did it he's buried out back
murph's brother tom is the only
character in interstellar whose fate is
a complete mystery so what exactly has
happened to coop's son by the time he
returns home from the tesseract well
logically the easiest answer is to
assume tom died for one he was older
than murph who is already extremely old
by the end so his time was naturally up
additionally in the final scenes of
interstellar we see that the only thing
allowing murph to hold onto her life is
a belief that her dad will return tom as
a character was defined by his lack of
faith and belief and coup his absence at
the end of the movie speaks to the power
of murph's love and hope and how they
were the only things keeping her alive
you can also argue that his single
purpose in the story is served in his
final scene tom's function in the plot
is ultimately to push murph to solve the
bookshelf puzzle his purpose is
fulfilled when she finally does and
afterward there really isn't any
narrative reason for tom to reappear
one of the more confusing world-building
elements is the current state of nasa in
the film it's never explained quite why
nasa folded though it seems that the
general populace and interstellar lost
faith in the organization years before
the events of the film basically what we
are given in the final film is that nasa
is no longer seen as necessary when
people all around the world are starving
this aspect of the movie is explained
more thoroughly in the 2008 original
script that christopher nolan's brother
jonathan worked on for steven spielberg
in that early draft the film begins with
nasa engineers and a young john brand
investigating a wormhole 50 years later
the nasa probe they had sent out crash
lands on earth this is eventually what
leads coop to nasa instead of the ghost
angle taken in the final film in the
early version of the story it is
explained that 30 years before the
film's events nasa folded as a result of
the blight that nearly destroyed all of
humanity
[Music]